i know that the prime minister will
report later in what there's been a way
a long time question one try again
the speaker it's only 15 years in my
case
another 18. uh thank you mr speaker
today
marks five days since the murder of our
friend and colleague joe cox my thoughts
and i'm sure those of the whole house
with her family and friends
mr speaker i'm sure that the house will
wish to join me in offering our thanks
and best wishes to
sir roy stone who is leaving the
government chief whips office
and the civil service he's worked for 13
chief whips
and for over 20 years has played an
invaluable role in delivering
the government of the day's legislative
program we wish him well
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with minister or colleagues
and others in addition to my duties in
this house i shall have further such
meetings
later today sir robert neal thank you mr
speaker
i'm sure we would all wish to associate
ourselves with the prime minister's
remarks
in relation both to joe cox and roy
stone
the prime minister i know will report
later in the house in more detail on the
g7 summit which i know
president biden described as extremely
collaborative
and successful in taking forward the
agenda and in particular
part of the agenda of the summit which
calls for us
to work to uphold the rule of law and
respect for an international rules-based
system
will he bear in mind and task all parts
of government to promote
the great asset that we have in english
common law
and in the expertise and reputation for
integrity
of our judiciary and legal systems we
make sure that those willing assets
are harnessed in the pursuit of that g7
agenda be it through
writing commercial contracts with
english law as a jurisdiction or helping
through our expertise developing
countries and markets prime minister
i thank my uh my right honourable friend
for his question he raises
a very important and vital sector of our
economy our legal services industry and
our judicial system which is admired
around the world one of the reasons
uh that we're capable of attracting so
much inward investment into this country
mr speaker
but also one of the key exports and this
is
mr speaker that we've been able to
promote just recently thanks for
instance to our free trade deal
with australia you know come to the
leader of the opposition
kirsten thank you mr speaker can i join
with the prime minister's remarks in
relation to sir roy
stone and this week also marks the
fourth anniversary of the grenfell fire
tragedy
where 72 people lost their lives
it's frankly an outrage that there are
still more than 200 high-rise flats
with grenfell style cladding and many
leaseholders are trapped in homes that
are neither safe
nor sellable the best way to mark this
tragedy is not with words
but with action and i urge the prime
minister finally to end the cladding
scandal
mr speaker as the prime minister has
already said today is the fifth
anniversary of the death of our dear
friend
and colleague joe cox joe had already
changed so many lives for the better
she was passionate about creating a
fairer more just world
i know she would have gone on to achieve
so much more
and that she would have been so proud of
the work of her foundation
and what it's doing in her name joe and
i were in the same intake
into this house we were friends and our
children around the same age
and there's not a day that goes by when
we don't miss joe
and i know i speak not just for these
benches but for many across the house
when i say that today we remember joe
mr speaker does the prime minister
recognize
that his decision to keep our borders
open
contributed to the spread of the delta
variant
in this country prime minister
uh no mr speaker i think that uh
captain hindsight needs to adjust his
retro his retro spectroscope because
he's completely wrong
we put india we put india on the red
list mr speaker
on april on april the 23rd
and the delta variant was not uh so
identified
until april uh the 28th uh mr speaker
and was only identified as a variant
of concern on may the seventh and mr
speaker when he
criticizes this government for wanting
to keep our borders there but just
remember that he voted 43 times
in the last five years mr speaker to
ensure that our border controls were
kept in the hands of brussels mr speaker
mr speaker this is absurd i have on
seven occasions
at pmq's raised the question of the
borders with the prime minister they're
all marked up in the transcript they're
all there in hansard
uh prime minister time for a better
defense their defense is as bad as your
border policy
mr speaker this is the prime minister
talks about the dates let's go through
the dates on march the 24th a new
variant was reported in india
on the first of april india was
reporting that over a hundred thousand
new infections
were rising a day and rising but the
prime minister kept india off the red
list until the 23rd of april
in that time 20 000 people came into the
uk from india
what on earth did the prime minister
expect would be the consequences
of that the british people did their bit
by following the rules and getting
vaccinated
but the prime minister squandered it by
letting a new variant into the country
that was not inevitable it was the
consequence of his indecision
if the prime minister disagrees with me
and he answered the first question no
what is his explanation as to why
britain
has such high rates of the delta
variation what's his
explanation prime minister mr speaker
there's a very simple reason why
the uk generally has a better
understanding of the variance in these
countries and that's because
we do 47 of the genomic testing anywhere
in the world uh mr speaker and i i
really think that he should get his
his fat straight because uh the the
delta value as i've said was identified
uh in this country on
uh april the 28th he and and i have a
document on which i believe the
leader of the opposition is is relying
mr speaker which he says that the delta
variant
it seems to be published by someone
called david evans uh of general
secretary of the labour party
uh saying that the delta variant was
identified on
april the first mr speaker he says b1617
i was designated under investigation on
april the first uh
the delta variant mr speaker that is not
the delta variant
that is the kappa variant mr speaker
it's a
it's a gamma uh mr speaker for the
labour party there's a difference
the delta variant as it happens is is
seeded around
the world in 74 countries and um sadly
is growing
but there's a difference between those
countries and this country mr speaker
in this country we've vaccinated almost
79
of the adult population and given two
vaccinations
to 56 percent a program that he would
have stopped mr speaker
by keeping us in the european medicines
agency
yes the question was what's his
explanation for our high rates
of the delta variant answer there came
none other than apparently we
understand the variant the data is very
very clear our nhs our nhs
has been doing an amazing job with the
vaccine rollout
but while the nhs was vaccinating he was
vacillating
it's because of his indecision that our
borders stayed open it's because of
his indecision that india stayed off the
red list it's because of his indecision
that in that period 20 000 people came
to this country from india
mr speaker the consequences are now
clear
the rate of the delta variant is much
higher here than in other countries
and we learned today that tragically
once again the uk has the highest
infection rate in europe
we did not want to top that table again
mr speaker if his borders policy is so
strong how does the prime minister
explain that
mrs b i think for the ease of the house
he should begin by pulping
his document in which he incorrectly
identifies what the delta variant
uh what the delta variant is uh which
and mr speaker we took uh the most
drastic steps possible but india on
the red list on april the 23rd before
that variant was even identified
and the the big difference between this
country and the rest of europe he loves
these
uh comparisons uh mr speaker it shows
his his instincts but the big difference
is that we've had the fastest
vaccine rollout anywhere in europe we
have a very very high degree of
protection and it's thanks to the
vaccine rollout thanks to the fantastic
efforts
of the nhs that we have now we can
continue
with one of the most open economies and
societies
in europe and get on and get on with our
cautious but irreversible
roadmap to freedom mr speaker here's
darma
mr speaker if the prime has put as much
effort into protecting our borders as he
does coming up with
ridiculous excuses the country will be
reopening next week
but even now what do we know the delta
responsible for 90
of infections in this country he's
persisting with a traffic light system
that doesn't work and won't stop other
variants coming in
mr speaker after so many mistakes and
with the stakes so high
why doesn't the prime minister do what
labour is calling for
drop the traffic light system get rid of
the amber list
secure the borders and do everything
possible to save
the british summer prime minister mr
speaker he doesn't even know what the
delta variant is
uh and he and he and we have the
toughest
we have the toughest border measures
anywhere in the world
and we will we will continue and we have
50 countries
only we have 50 countries on the red
list mr speaker and if he's now saying
if he's now saying that he wants to stop
all transit all traffic all travel to
and from this country
then it's yet another flip-flop from the
labour
leader of the opposition yet another yet
another totally unintelligible
flip-flop it's because he wants to if he
wants to close this country down
uh to travel to what i understood him uh
to be saying uh then it's not only a
yet another flip-flop but it's also
totally pointless because we have
75 percent of our medicines and 50 of
our food
that comes in from abroad mr speaker
he's got he's going to adopt a
consistent position
girl stammer you're saying that mr
speaker
what i've learned the worse the position
for the prime minister the more pathetic
he gets
is he really suggesting is he really
suggesting that the 20 000 people who
came in from india
were bringing in vital medical supplies
or food it's ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous what we were
arguing for
is for india to be on the red list
between the first and the 23rd of april
if that had happened
we wouldn't have the delta variant here
and it's as simple as
that the prime minister's former senior
adviser got it absolutely right
he said and i quote fundamentally there
was no proper border policy because
the prime minister never wanted a proper
border policy
the man who was in the room and it's
those in hospitality
in clubs in pubs the arts tourism and
travel
who are paying the price of the prime
minister's failure
all they ask is that they if they have
to keep their businesses closed
they get the support that they need but
where is it
business rate relief is being withdrawn
from the end of this month
affecting 750 000 businesses furlough is
being phased out
mr speaker in wales the labor government
has acted
by extending business rate relief for a
year and providing new support for those
affected
when is the prime minister going to do
the same for businesses
in england prime minister mr speaker
we're
proud of the support we've given to
businesses up and down the country and
the whole point about the cautious
approach
uh that we are taking is to continue
support the both with furlough and with
uh support through business rates
through uh grants of up to eighteen
thousand pounds
uh the support from councils uh all of
that is is continuing but what we're
also
seeing is uh we're seeing businesses
slowly
uh recovering and the growth in the
economy in april was 2.3 percent
uh card spending over the bank holiday
weekend was actually 20
above uh pre-pandemic levels mr speaker
i know how tough
things have been and we will look after
business throughout this pandemic but
thanks to the vaccine rollout thanks to
the cautious steps
uh we are taking we are seeing a shot in
the arm for business
across the country and we will look
after them all the way
vicar yes again it's not what the
government has done it's what's needed
now in light of the decision that was
taken this week
hospitality uk says the sector will lose
three billion pounds because of the
delay
and that two hundred thousand jobs could
be at risk that's not what has been done
it's what's needed now prime minister
and the federation of small businesses
warns the government is being
dangerously complacent i think we've
just seen an example of that
mr speaker we all want these
restrictions to be over
for our economy to be open for
businesses to thrive
but the prime minister's indecision at
the borders has blown it
and the problem with the problem with
everything the prime minister says today
both only says dispatch box and also
what he mutters
um is that we've heard it all before so
many
times last last month march
he said we could turn the tide in 12
weeks remember that
then he said it will all be over by
christmas then we were told june 21st
would be freedom day
now we're told july 19th is terminus day
the british people don't expect miracles
but they do expect
basic competence and honesty and when it
comes to
care homes protective equipment or
borders we see the same
pattern from this prime minister too
slow too indecisive
over promising under delivery
after all these failures are mistakes
why should anyone believe the prime
minister now
mr speaker why should anybody believe
the leader of the opposition
uh when he can't uh when he can't he
can't decide what he thinks from one
week to the next he says he has a
tough position on borders actually he
was attacking uh quarantine
uh only recently and saying and saying
that it was a blunt instrument that we
should be lessened
uh mr speaker uh what i think the people
this country want to see is the
government getting on
with the vaccine rollout and getting on
uh with our cautiously irreversible
roadmap to freedom and i'm very pleased
and that he he should say it again
uh that we have one of the fastest
vaccine riots anywhere in the world
certainly the fastest
in europe it would not have been
possible if we'd stayed in the ema
we would not have been able to control
our borders if as he voted for 43 times
uh mr speaker we'd stayed in the in the
eu
uh we're getting on uh with the job
we're bringing forward now
23 24 year olds for asking them to come
forward for their vaccines i ask
everybody to come forward for their
second jab i trust
uh he has had his mr speaker and we are
delivering on our commitments
to the british people not only a a great
outcome at the g7
summit uh this last weekend in carbus
bay but a new free trade agreement uh
with australia
and a building back better across our
country we're getting on
uh with a job mr speaker and it would be
a wonderful thing
uh once in his uh time as leader of the
opposition to hear some support
for what the government is doing and and
and
and and some backing up for our approach
paul brister
thank you mr speaker last year doctors
and care settings issued an
unprecedented number of do not
resuscitate orders to patients
with learning disabilities and mental
illness many
were unlawful and caused avoidable
deaths despite urgent cqc and nhs
guidance
shockingly this practice has continued
last week the telegraph
reported that sonia deleon died
unresuscitated
her family said she was given a dnr
without them knowing
and with her learning disabilities and
schizophrenia stated as reasons
does the prime minister share my alarm
about these cases
which should have no place in our care
and does he agree that they should be
independently
investigated prime minister uh
mr speaker i thank my honourable friend
for raising this this very sad
case with me and i'm sure the whole
house uh will be
thinking of sonia deleon and her family
i think that
such uh decisions on uh
do not attempt uh do do not resuscitate
uh should be made only uh in accordance
with
uh a decision uh involving the person
concerned
and their carers and their families mr
speaker
we now come to the smp leader ian
blackford
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks that you made
the prime minister and the
leader of the opposition and the
absolutely brutal death of our friend
and colleague
joe cox five years ago a woman that was
dedicated to
public service that made in a short time
here a tremendous contribution to this
house and our thoughts are very much
with
her family her friends and all those
that care very deeply
for her loss and of course as we do that
we should also reflect on
what we saw earlier this week with the
journalist nick watt chased through the
streets
of whitehall by a mob seeking to
intimidate and we must all stand up in
this house
for the rights of journalists to be able
to go around their work safely
i say mr speaker good wishes both to
scotland and england
ahead of the football match on friday
evening but if i
if i if i may say so i do hope that
we don't see scotland being dragged out
of the euros against
our wishes at the end of the week
mr speaker as we as we as we enter the
chamber we see what is reported to be
whatsapp communication between the prime
minister and dominic cummings and
perhaps the prime minister
will clarify whether or not these are
genuine and whether derogatory comments
are
expressed on its health secretary are
valid or not
mr speaker this morning the details of
the disastrous trade deal with australia
are slowly seeping out it tells us
everything that we need to know that
these details are being celebrated in
canberra
but they're busy being concealed in
london
for all the spin it's clear that this
tory government has just
thrown scottish farmers and crafters
under their brexit bus
just as they sold out our fishing
community so today
those with most to lose from this deal
don't need to hear the prime minister's
usual
waffle their livelihoods are at stake
prime minister
just this once just this once they
deserve honest answers
from this government can the prime
minister confirm
that from day one of this deal 35 000
tons of australian beef
and 25 000 tons of australian lamb will
be free to flood the uk market
tariff free minister mr speaker this is
a
great deal for the uk it's a great deal
for
scotland uh it's a great deal for
scottish whiskey it's a great deal for
scottish
uh business and and services exports
it's great deal for scottish legal
services but it's also a great deal for
scottish
farming and how tragic how absolutely
tragic that it should be the posture of
the
uh of the scottish national party mr
speaker
to see absolutely no way in which uh
scottish farmers could be uh able to
take advantage
of the opportunity to export around
there what they really doesn't realize
is that already are 350 million pounds
worth
of uk food going from uh this country uh
to australia this is an opportunity
to turbo charge uh those exports to get
behind
uh scottish farming and encourage them
mr speaker not run them down
in blackfoot my goodness i don't even
think the prime minister can believe
that tripe
mr speaker in the tory's desperation
to get a post-brexit trade deal with
somebody with anybody
they've given the farm away literally
it is blindingly obvious who the winners
and who are the losers in this deal
australia's economy will benefit to the
tune
of 1.3 billion dollars a year
the uk government's own assessment says
the australian deal is worth just
and i quote 0.02
of gdp mr speaker you would need
200 australian deals to come close to
mitigating
the cost of brexit we were told that
brexit
was all about taking back control but
for our farmers
and for our crafters there's been no
scrutiny
there's been no consultation and there's
been no consent
so if the prime minister is really
confident about the benefits
of this deal does he have the guts to
put it to a vote
in this house
mr speaker the people of this country
voted uh
for this government to get on and
deliver free trade deals
around the world and i believe they were
totally right
uh he talks about about tripe mr speaker
i can tell him uh that when it comes to
exporting the intestines of
of sheep which i know is a valuable part
of scottish tradition
even that is now being opened up around
the world thanks for the deals
that this country is doing and and mr
speaker if if he
if he is saying if he is saying uh that
he wants to
go back into the eu hand back control of
our fisheries
hand back control of our agriculture to
brussels
uh lose all the opportunities that this
country has gained i think he is frankly
out of his mind
and and going in totally the wrong
direction and if he means a referendum
another referendum mr speaker we had one
of those
can i just say gently to everybody we
need no need to turbo
charge questions and answers thank you
mr speaker
thanks to our unique geography the high
peak has some of the worst
broadband and mobile coverage gaps
anywhere in the country
we are making good progress but can i
urge the prime minister
to redouble efforts in the rollout of
ultra fast broadband
especially to hard to reach rural areas
like the high peak and can i suggest the
government builds on the success
of the kickstart scheme with more
focused support for key infrastructure
industries
so that we can recruit a new generation
of highly skilled broadband engineers
to turbo charge the rollout yes prime
minister
i thank my honorable friend my own
friend he's absolutely right
and uh that's why we're working with
industry to accelerate our
uh rural network and uh coverage across
the whole of the uk has massively
increased and will be increasing
thanks to the steps that we're taking so
jeffrey dunst
thank you mr speaker i know like me the
prime minister cares passionately
about the union can the prime minister
therefore confirm
that the passing of the eu withdrawal
act
and the northern ireland protocol that
forms part of it
has not resulted in an implied repeal
of article six of the active union which
enables northern ireland to trade freely
with the rest of this united kingdom and
will he commit
to fully restoring northern ireland's
place within
the uk internal market prime minister
yes of course mr speaker i can give
assurances on both uh those counts and i
can say that unless we
uh see uh progress on the implementation
of the protocol which i think is
currently
uh totally uh disproportionate then we
will have to take
the necessary steps uh to do exactly
what he says
you mr speaker does my right honourable
friend agree with me that the rebuild
of hillingdon hospital will be a great
benefit to his constituents
and mine and will he commit to working
with me and other local members of
parliament and potential future mps like
peter fleet and chesham and amisham
to secure the future of services at
hillingdon's other site mount vernon
in my constituency which provides
specialist medical treatments to a very
wide catchment area
prime minister i thank my honourable
friend he's totally right about
hillingdon
hospital which has a a great future and
uh we will make sure
and i look forward to working uh with
him uh and to make sure that
the future of services at mount vernon
uh is all is also
uh protected and i know that a full
consultation is due to start in
september
thank you mr speaker kevin a hotel
manager in oxford contacted me last week
because he's worried
because even if this country does open
up in the next few weeks he won't be
able to run at full capacity due to
chronic staff
shortages local staff are leaving the
industry
because of the uncertainty caused by
this government's bungled
handling of this pandemic the eu staff
have already left
because of the botched handling of
brexit and he can't recruit from abroad
because of the damaging new immigration
policy
this is the prime minister's wake up
call oxfordshire's economy alone
relies on the hospitality industry to
the tune of two and a half billion
pounds will the government introduce a
covert recovery visa
to help kevin recruit the staff he
desperately needs
yeah mr speaker
it's absolutely true that as we open up
our economy there is
a there are more vacancies and that's
that's great but we also have
large numbers of people in this country
mr speaker large numbers of
young people uh who need jobs uh and
large numbers of people who are still
furloughed and i think what we want to
see is those people coming forward
to get those jobs but of course we will
we will retain
an open and a flexible approach towards
allowing talent
to come in from overseas thank you mr
speaker the prime minister knows the
full value of the uk shellfish industry
and the opportunity potential that there
is
this week the food standards agency
produced a list of recommendations that
will allow us to regrade our waters
challenge anomalous results however
those recommendations only come in
september this year
will the prime minister flex his muscles
and see
if the report and the recommendation
could be brought forward to the end of
this month
mr speaker i will do everything i can to
ensure that
we accelerate this uh process he's right
to raise it a great deal of progress
has already been made and uh the food
standards agency has i think been
uh flexible but we need to go further
and we'll
make sure that great british shellfish
can continue to be exported
uh to europe and around the world marine
fellows
the uk government's trade deal with
australia has been made with no
consultation
no consent and no parliamentary scrutiny
the president of the national union
scotland has said
our seafood industry has already been
hit hard
by brexit and now scottish farming will
be sacrificed
again it's scotland's key industries
which will bear the brunt of a tory
brexit
people in scotland did not vote for
does the prime minister think these
concerns from nfu scotland president
and does he accept them or does he think
that he knows better prime minister mr
speaker you think from listening to the
snp
that there were there was no uh scotch
whiskey industry or no
thank you financial services industries
uh in scotland
but even then uh they're missing the
point because this is a massive
opportunity for the scottish
agriculture sector what they need what
they need is a different type of mp
uh mr speaker who can champion them who
can get behind them who actually
believes in scotland
uh mr speaker that's what the people of
scotland needs
thank you mr speaker one of the reasons
for the popularity of the prime minister
is that he's always been on the side
he's always been on the side of the
public rather than on the side of the
establishment
given that overall given the overall
deaths in the uk
over the last 13 weeks are 8
873 below the five year average
which includes the time the indian
variant has been around
can my right honourable friend explain
why instead of trusting his
world-leading vaccine program
the common sense of the british people
and his conservative instincts of
individual freedom and individual
responsibility
he instead prefers to trust people like
professor
susan mickey at sage a long-standing
member of the communist party
who last week let the cat out of the bag
and said she wanted some covered
restrictions
to last forever prime minister
uh mr speaker nobody uh uh at least will
uh i or my honorable friend want to see
kovid restrictions
last forever nor do i think that they
are are going to last
forever mr speaker as i made clear
earlier this week i think we can have a
high degree of confidence
that our program our vaccination program
will work and i think we need to give it
a little bit more time as i've explained
to save many thousands more lives by
vaccinating
millions more people that's what we want
to do
thank you mr speaker my constituent ross
has been invited to sit his driving
theory test in
auburn 100 miles away from his home in
hamilton
his test is already been cancelled twice
first in november last year
and then february 2021 this september
ross is starting a university course
in paramedic science with a view to
becoming a qualified paramedic
in the scottish ambulance service with
placements across scotland
being able to drive is crucial will the
prime minister meet with me to discuss
the delays
in the scheduling of dvsa theory tests
and the impracticality of the locations
being offered to you yeah
yes i thank the honourable lady i am
aware of the
of the problem and we're doing what we
can to accelerate uh the number of
driving instructors and testers so
uh to allow young people such as the the
gentleman she mentions to get their
their driving test done and enable them
to fulfill their their ambitions
mr speaker i support the prime
minister's comments on joe cox and also
as a former chief whip his comment on
sirois stone sarai
gave amazing service to me as chief whip
during the worst of the brexit years in
dealing with the hung parliament
and with the odd occasional disruptive
adventure
mr speaker northern ireland faces some
challenges
uh over the coming weeks in terms of
nominating a first and deputy first
minister
would the prime minister agree with me
that it's vital that
parties stick to the agreements that
have been made the new decade new
approach which he and i negotiated 18
months ago
and that in failing to do that we
ultimately and only doesn't like this
concept
that the uk government does act as a
backstop yes
prime minister i i will give me great
pleasure to thank
uh my right honourable friend for all
the work that he did in the new
decade new approach uh deal uh and
i i do agree that uh it will be a good
thing for
the whole package to be uh agreed and i
and and i certainly support the approach
that he uh that he set out
and i think that what the the people of
northern ireland want is a
is a stable functioning a mature
executive
kenny mccaskill thank you mr speaker a
new lord advocate
is taking up position but the structural
flaws in the office remain
in no other legal jurisdiction in the uk
or indeed in the western world
is a government senior legal adviser
simultaneously the country's chief
prosecutor
yet the role is enshrined in the
scotland act 1988
will the prime minister commit to
changes so that this historical
anachronism can be
changed and a separation of powers be
achieved
prime minister uh well
first of all speaking i congratulate the
uh honourable gentleman on his own
outstanding success of his party in the
recent
uh elections uh but uh i will i will
study the
anomaly that he uh he raises and revert
to him
as soon as possible thank you mr speaker
can i welcome the publication of the
tigger report today
um published by my right honourable
friend for chingford and woodford greene
my right honourable friend for chipping
barnet and my honourable friend from mid
norfolk
the report makes recommendations about
how to seize new opportunities from
brexit and back startups and new tech
will my right honourable friend look
closely at that report
so that we can make the most of the
great benefits of brexit and lead the
world in the development of new
technology
uh yes mr speaker i thank my uh
honorable might honourable friends for
their excellent report i think it's time
to
put a tigger in the tank ellen days
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks concerning the
fifth anniversary of the murder of joe
cox
joe is a dear personal friend and
colleague who will always be missed and
remembered
and whose extraordinary legacy endures
far beyond this place
mr speaker last month a fire in an east
london block of flats
caused three people to be hospitalized
and dozens more to be treated for smoke
inhalation
that block was one of more than 200
high-rise buildings in england
still fitted with grenfell style
cladding i asked the prime minister
why is it that four years after the
grenfell tragedy
took 72 lives after all the warnings
all the tireless campaigning and the
unspeakable injustice
people are still living in unsafe flats
and his government has failed to end the
cladding scandal
yeah mr speaker we have invested
massively in removing cladding from
uh from high rise blocks will continue
to do so i know the bill the structure
in question the
the ballymore the company concerned i i
do believe we're
too slow and we are on their case mr
speaker but i think it is very very
important
uh very very important that people
understand that
overall risks of death by fire have been
coming down for a very long time
and will continue to come down and it is
simply not the case that all the
high-rise buildings in this country
are unsafe and very important that
members of parliament
should stress that paul holmes thank you
mr speaker independent lifeboat stations
like the hamburgle lifeboat in my
constituency respond to over 100
incidents a year in the solent
the pandemic has increased the operating
costs of independent lifeboat stations
while also restricting their ability to
raise money will the prime minister to
look to see to what more the government
can do to support independent lifeboat
stations like the handball lifeboat
as they keep a watchful eye on all of us
prime minister uh
yes indeed mr speaker i thank my
honourable friend uh for raising the
excellent work of humble
uh lifeboats and uh with the my
in april last year uh my right-hand
friend chancellor put forward another
750 million
pounds in support of uh charities such
as the one he mentions
sure mr speaker at two venues in glasgow
hospitality venues called blue dog and
adlib
staff there have had no furlough
payments since the summer of last year
having raised this with hmrc directly
the situation still hasn't moved forward
if i send him the details will he knock
heads together
help the staff whose bills are going
unpaid and debts are rising
and get the cash into their accounts
they're entitled to so we're very happy
to look at it mr speaker
liam like when can we expect the
coordinated chorus of
sage members recommencing their media
appearances to depress bural
and does my rational friend fear having
to give another press conference at
which he again
postpones the return of our freedoms mr
speaker we are rightly told that we need
to learn to live with kobe
so what can the prime minister say to
the country to convince us of that
reality
yeah prime minister mr speaker i believe
that academic and scientific freedom are
an invaluable part of our
uh our country uh and uh i also i also
note that
uh my scientific colleagues would echo
my sentiments that we need to learn
to live with kobe mr speaker macklin
thank you mr speaker
this government's two child cap and its
child care proof of payment rules
mean my hard-working constituent miss
cowan who's a single parent
on universal credit supporting four kids
faces one thousand pounds of nurse
arrears she's therefore at risk of
losing their nursery places
she would therefore have to give up work
and would therefore be at risk of
sanction and forced further into debt
and poverty can the prime minister help
my constituent out of this trap
and will he fix these rules that are
pushing people out of work
and into poverty prime minister uh mr
speaker i'd be happy to study the case
but the whole point of universal credit
uh which this government introduces it's
helping uh hundreds of thousands of
people
into work it's a and that is its success
jason mccarthy uh thank you mr speaker
and i
associate myself with the comments of
the prime minister and the leader of the
opposition about our friend joe cox
will the prime minister join me in
congratulating rugby league legend kevin
sinfield
for his obe and the queen's birthday
honours kevin has done
so much to raise awareness of motor
neurone disease
and support his good friend rob burrow
mnd is a devastating
disease there's no cure but scientists
mr speaker believe they're on the cusp
of developing effective treatments so
will the government please
commit to investing 50 million pounds
over five years
to establish a virtual m d research
institute
and accelerate research
thank you and it's an obe mr speaker i
also thank kevin fitzgerald
uh very much for his outstanding work
and uh we're following it up
uh with we're spending 55 million pounds
on research into
into mnd but there will be more to come
as part of our general
massive investment in in life sciences
customers
thank you mr speaker the trade deal the
prime minister has struck
simply put means undercutting our
farmers
short-changing consumers and it will set
animal welfare standards back
by decades the rspca have said
that the prime minister's deal will and
i quote
start a race to the bottom and the
losers will be billions of farmed
animals
and uk farmers does the prime minister
accept
these concerns from the experts at the
rspca
or does he think that he knows better
prime minister
i really think that these constant
attacks on australia and
their standards and their animal welfare
standards would be very very much
presented by the people of australia and
they'd be they not would not be
recognized
actually australia is marked five out of
five which is the highest possible
by the world organization of animal
health performance and veterinary
services evaluation team for animal
welfare
and uh this deal mr speaker that we've
done is the first
ever to incorporate high animal welfare
status standards
as part of the package that australia
has agreed luciano
thank you mr speaker will my right
honourable friend
join me in paying tribute to assisted
dying campaigner noel conway
who has died after taking the decision
to have his breathing support removed
and does my right honourable friend
agree
that it is now time for parliament to
properly consider the law on assisted
dying mr speaker i believe this is a
subject
and i thank my honourable friend uh and
i i know that the whole house will be in
sympathy with noel conway's
family and friends uh
there are very very deeply and sincerely
held views on both sides of this matter
a change in the law would be one
obviously for parliament to consider mr
speaker over the course of this
question session the prime minister has
been presented with the views of
stakeholder
after stakeholder expressing real fears
and concerns over these
bungled trade talks why is the prime
minister willing to put the livelihoods
of farmers and crafters across scotland
in peril
for a shoddy trade deal with australia
they won't even cover one percent of the
lost opportunities to europe's markets
that we've lost through brexit prime
minister
mr speaker we haven't lost opportunities
to europe's markets through brexit
final question ben spence thank you mr
speaker in 2014 running medium weight
bridge was hit by devastating floods my
constituents live under fear of flooding
last week the government signed off the
online business case for river thames
for the aviation scheme
which will allow the detailed design and
planning for this scheme to begin
an earnest it's fantastic news a
monumental milestone
will massively improve our protection
flooding will the prime minister join in
celebrating
thanking everyone's got to this point
and where we are and agreeing with me we
need to keep the momentum going
i thank my honorable friend he's
completely right and the
uh the uh 500 1 million pound river 10
scheme
uh will reduce the flood risk for eleven
thousand homes and sixteen thousand
uh businesses and i thank him uh for
raising it with me today
that concludes the question so i'm now
going to go straight to the statement
i now call the prime minister to make
the statement prime minister
mr speaker with permission i will make a
statement
on the g7 summit i chaired in carbus bay
in the nato summit in brussels
let me first thank the people of
cornwall carbus base
dives uh for welcoming the
representatives of the world's most
powerful democracies
to their home and enchanting setting for
the first
gathering of g7 leaders in two years the
first
since the pandemic began and president
biden's first
overseas visit since taking office our
aim was to demonstrate how the world's
democracies are ready and able
to address the world's toughest problems
offering solutions
and backing them up with concrete action
the g7 will combine our strengths and
expertise
to defeat kovid minimize the risk of
another pandemic
and build back better fairer and greener
for the benefit of all alongside our
partners the g7 is now engaged
in the biggest and fastest vaccination
program
in history designed to protect the whole
world by the end
of next year my fellow leaders agreed to
supply developing countries
with another billion doses either
directly or through other channels
of which 100 million will come from the
uk
the world's most popular vaccine was
developed here and the express purpose
of the deal between the british
government
oxford university and astrazeneca was to
create a not
an inoculation that would be easy to
distort
to store quick to distribute and
available
at cost price or zero profit to protect
as many people
as possible the results are becoming
clearer every day
over 500 million oxford astrozenica
vaccines have been
administered in 168 countries so far
accounting for 96 of the doses
distributed to developing nations by
kovacs
the global alliance that the uk helped
to establish
with every passing hour people are being
protected across the world and lives
saved
by the formidable expertise that the uk
was able to assemble but all the efforts
of this country
and of many others no matter how
generous
and far sighted would be futile in the
face
of another lethal virus that might
escape our efforts so the g7 has agreed
to support a global pandemic radar
to spot new pathogens before they begin
to spread allowing
immediate containment and in case a new
virus gets through anyway
our scientists will embark on a mission
to develop the ability to create new
vaccines
treatments and tests in just 100 days
compared to the 300 required for kobe
even as we persevere against this
virus my fellow leaders share my
determination
to look beyond today's crisis and build
back better
greener and fairer if we can learn
anything from this tragedy we have at
least
been given a chance to break with the
past and do things better
and do them differently this time
as our economies rebound we must avoid
the mistakes
we made after the financial crash of
2008
and ensure that everyone benefits from
the recovery
the surest way of our future prosperity
is to design
fair and open rules and standards for
the new frontiers
of the global economy so the g7 will
devise a fairer tax system for global
corporations reversing the race to the
bottom
and strive to ensure that new technology
serves as a force for prosperity
and hope strengthening freedom and
openness
my fellow leaders will act as one
against an increasing injustice
the denial of an education to millions
of girls
across the world by working to get
another 40 million girls
into school by 2025 i'm happy to say
that the g7 agreed to provide more than
half
of the 5 billion sought by the global
partnership for education
to transform the prospects of millions
of children in developing countries
and 430 million pounds and will come
from
the uk our duty to future
generations compels us to protect
our planet from catastrophic climate
change
and every country in the g7 has promised
to achieve
net zero by 2050 wiping out our
contribution to global warming
from that date onwards and to achieve
that target
we will halve our carbon emissions by
2030
compared with 2010 levels the g7
resolved to end
any government support for unabated
coal-fired
power generation overseas and
increase and improve climate finance
between now
and 2025 we will consecrate
30 percent of our land and sea to nature
protecting fast areas in all their
abundance and diversity
of life giving millions of species the
chance to recover
from the ravages of recent decades
and it is precisely because safeguarding
safeguarding our planet
requires global action that the g7
will offer developing countries a new
partnership
the buildback better world to help
construct
new and clean gr and green
infrastructure
in a way that is transparent and
environmentally
responsible there is no contradiction
between averting climate change and
creating highly skilled
and well-paid jobs both in our country
and around
the world we can and will achieve both
by means of a green industrial
revolution at home and green
infrastructure aboard abroad i was
honored to welcome our friends the
leaders of india
south korea australia and south africa
as guests in carbus bay and virtually of
course in the case
of the prime minister of india and on
monday scott morrison and i
were delighted to reach a free trade
agreement between the uk
and australia creating fantastic
opportunities for both
our countries eliminating tariffs on all
british
exports whether scotch whiskey or cars
from the midlands
and making it easier for young british
people
to live and work in australia
we've also included protections for
british farmers
over the next 15 years and unprecedented
protections and provisions for animal
welfare
and this house will of course be able to
scrutinize the agreement
once the texts are finalized this is
exactly how global britain
will help to generate jobs and
opportunities at home
and level up our whole united kingdom
our agreement with australia
is a vital step towards the even greater
prize
of the uk joining the trans-pacific
partnership
a nine trillion dollar free trade area
embracing the fastest growing
economies of the world together with the
g7
the countries represented at carbes bay
comprise a democratic eleven three
nations
living on five continents spanning
different faiths and cultures but united
by a shared belief in liberty democracy
and human rights those ideals were
encapsulated in the atlantic charter
agreed by winston churchill and
president roosevelt in 1941 when britain
was the only surviving democracy
in europe and the very existence of our
freedom was in peril
the courage and valor of millions of
people ensured
our ideals survived and flourished and
80 years on president biden and i
met within sight of hms prince of wales
the royal navy's newest aircraft carrier
and the linear successor
of the battleship on which the original
charter was devised
and we agreed a new atlantic charter
encompassing the full breadth
of british and american cooperation in
science technology trade
and global security the surest guarantee
of our security is nato which protects a
billion people
in 30 countries and the summit in
brussels on monday
agreed the wholesale modernization of
the alliance to meet new dangers
including in space and cyprus cyberspace
reflecting the priorities of our own
integrated review
of foreign and defence policy britain
has the biggest defense budget in europe
comfortably exceeding the nato target of
two percent of national income
we have committed our nuclear deterrent
and our cyber capabilities
to the alliance and we contribute more
troops than
any other countries to to nato's
than any other country to nato's
deployment to protect poland
and the baltic states we do more for the
security of our continent than any
other european power showing that we
mean it
when we say that an attack on any nato
ally shall be considered an attack on
all
a pledge that has kept the peace for
over 70 years
and which president biden reaffirmed on
behalf
of the united states together these two
summits showed the enduring strength
of the atlantic alliance and the bonds
we treasure
with kindred democracies across the
globe
they provided the best possible
foundation for cop 26 in glasgow in
november
when the uk will bring the whole world
together
in a common cause they demonstrated how
global britain creates jobs
at home while striving in unison with
our friends
for a greener safer
and fairer world and mr speaker i
commend this statement to the house
welcome to the leader of the opposition
kia stammer
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement
mr speaker it was a labour government
and a labour foreign secretary
ernest bevin that helped found nato
and it's an alliance that labour will
always value and protect
and so we welcome agreement on the nato
2030 agenda
in particular strengthening nato's cyber
security capability
we also welcome the deepening support
for our friends and allies
in ukraine and georgia recognition of
the global security implications
of the climate emergency and for the
first time
of the challenges that china poses to
global security
and stability on the uk
austria trade deal mr speaker we all
want to see britain
taking trading opportunities around the
world
but the devil will be in the detail and
we look forward to scrutinizing this
deal
in parliament in particular for its
impact on british farmers
and on food standards mr speaker turning
to the
g7 summit this should have been the most
important g7 in a generation
the first of the recovery the first with
a new us
president a chance for britain to lead
the world
as we did at glen eagles in 2005
or after the global financial crisis in
2009
but whether on global vaccination the
climate emergency
middle east peace or the northern
ireland protocol
this summit ended up as a wasted
opportunity
mr speaker the priority for the summit
had to be a clear pan
plan to vaccinate the world this is not
just a moral imp
imperative it's in our self-interest as
the delta variant makes clear
without global vaccine coverage this
virus will continue to boomerang
bringing more variants and more
disruption to these shores
the world health organization has said
that 11 billion doses are needed 11
billion doses
this summit promised less than one tenth
of that no new funding
no plan to build a global vaccine
capability capacity
and no progress on patent waivers
mr speaker the headlines of a billion
doses may be what the prime minister
wanted
but it's not what the world needed
the same is true of the climate
emergency this is the single greatest
challenge the world will face in decades
to come
but this summit saw no progress on
climate finance
the communique speaks only of
commitments already
made and of those yet to be made
there was no plan let alone a martial
plan to speed up
cuts to global emissions and there was
little in the communique beyond existing
commitments
mr speaker this summit was meant to be a
stepping stone to cop26
but if anything it was a step back
it was also disappointing that there was
nothing to suggest any progress was made
to restart middle east peace process
a new government in israel combined with
a new u.s president
provides a real opportunity to end the
injustice
and to finally deliver an independent
and sovereign palestine
alongside a safe and secure israel and
the resumption
sadly of hostilities overnight shows the
price
of that failure so can i ask the prime
minister if he discussed this with world
leaders
including president biden
the summit should also have been an
opportunity to resolve
not inflamed tensions over the northern
ireland protocol
it started with an unprecedented
diplomatic rebuke
from our closest allies and it ended
with the white house still speaking of
candid discussions and he was
overshadowed by the failure of the prime
minister to make the deal that he
negotiated he negotiated
work mr speaker the prime minister may
think this is all part of a grand
diplomatic game
but northern ireland is far too serious
for that
when a prime minister loses the trust of
our allies
and trashes britain's reputation for
upholding upholding international law
it's hardly surprising that we're left
isolated and unable
to leave mr speaker despite all this i
have no doubt the prime minister will be
pleased with the g7
because it delivered it delivered
everything that he wanted
some good headlines some nice photos
and even a row with the french over
sausages
but that just shows that just shows how
narrow the prime minister's ambition for
britain really is
it's why this was never going to be a
glenn eagle's type style
success and why the prime minister
played the role of host
but not leader of tour guide but not
statesman
on those terms this g7 was a success on
any other
it was a failure thank you mr speaker
prime minister
well mr speaker i think in a long career
of miserablism and defeatism
uh i think he's really it's excelled
himself there
uh let me it was it was a a a very
powerful statement
after a long and difficult period uh in
which the world came together
and uh decided to build back better for
the world and
uh one of the things he he didn't
mention was of course uh the
fantastic agreement uh we reached uh to
to come together and support the whole
of the developing world which i think he
should
approve of uh in in allowing them uh to
have access to clean
green technology financed by the
multilateral
national and development banks but
bringing in the private sector
from around the world it's a fantastic
step forward for the world he
he's he he nickels and dimes uh what
happened on vaccines
i think it was fantastic uh the the the
world agreed
the world agree on top of the billion uh
we've already done
uh the world agreed another billion
another billion vaccines mr speaker
uh when when when people are racing to
vaccinate
their own populations they agreed
another billion vaccines
uh from the g7 a hundred million more
from this country
and and you're always constantly running
this country's efforts down mr speaker
of the 1.5 billion kovacs vaccines that
have already been distributed let me
remind him 500 million of them are
directly due
to the efforts of this country which has
given 1.6 billion pounds
to supporting kovacs and and another 546
uh just before and 48 to supporting
gabby as for climate change i mean i
don't know what
what planet he's on mr speaking we are
with this was an
extraordinary achievement by the summit
in
uh getting not only did all countries
commit to
to net zero by by 2050 but we're very
largely
now a long way there in getting in
getting the 100 billion
uh we need for climate change uh climate
change financing
uh mr speaker uh he he he uh
complains about uh the the northern
ireland
uh protocol mr speaker he's not at all
clear uh what he believes
himself it's not at all clear he says
he's not in favor of
of checks at the no of the northern
irish uh the border between
uh great britain or northern ireland
there should be no border he says he's
quite right then what is his policy
that's exactly what this government is
standing for i like i'd like to
understand what he actually stands for
uh for once
uh mr speaker uh finally finally mr
speaker
we want we want to get rid of those
checks
and if he will support us in in doing so
then i would i would be glad grateful
finally for his support uh he he
said that he i think he said something
positive about the nato
uh summit uh i'm glad of that that
is striking uh that he's not joined by
uh for once by the shadow
uh foreign secretary on these benches uh
since as far as
she it is still her view as far as i can
remember that we should get rid of the
nuclear deterrent our own nuclear
deterrent on which our nato
security guarantee uh relies
and as for the as for the trade deal as
for the trade deal with australia
mr speaker as for this maybe that's what
happens
maybe she's changing as for the trade
deal with australia uh mr speaker
the the shadow the shadow international
trade secretary
has herself said uh that she doesn't
think it's possible
for the uk to export uh food and drink
to australia because to quote her it
goes off
mr speaker it goes off actually this
country exports 350 million pounds worth
of food and drink uh he should
congratulate uh uk exporters
support the free trade deal and stop
being so generally down in the mouth
about everything
mr speaker can i uh welcome my right
away from the prime minister's
leadership of the g7 over the weekend
and many of its successful uh outcomes
but during the g7 the united states
uh proposed that they adopt all of them
a common strategy on china's
disgusting's used
of forced labor and confront them i
understand that some of the european
countries
dissented from this approach and i
therefore asked my runnable friend
does he stand with president biden on
this issue
not his dissenters and if so will he
emphasize
this by informing the house when the
government will bring forward its
promised export controls
to keeps goods made by uyghur slave
labor off
our shelves and the promised changes to
the modern slavery act these are very
important
and the prime minister can re-emphasize
his strong credentials
prime minister um i'm great for my role
we've already put in
uh magnitsky sanctions against those
involved in
uh in forced labor uh
in uh in xinjiang and uh we will
continue to have very tough
export measurable import measures to
import controls on any such
produce
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement after a week of ascending to
the
heavy heights of hosting global leaders
i can sense just how
thrilled the prime minister is to be
back in this house answering questions
from us
mere mortals but even us mere mortals
looking at the g7 from afar we can
detect the difference
between a welcoming host and an
influential leader
because even a raft of carefully crafted
photo opportunities in cornwall
couldn't hide the fact that this prime
minister and his government
are deeply diminished in the world stage
mr speaker the uk
is the only g7 country cutting overseas
aid
the only g7 country being questioned
about its commitment
to previously signed international
treaties and the uk remains
the g7 country with the smallest
the smallest covered stimulus package
so whilst the prime minister may have
hoped to
relaunch global britain what was really
on show over the last week
was brexit britain a more isolated
and a less influential place prior to
the summit
the prime minister built up the
prospects of a
new marshall plan promoting climate
action in developing countries
but what was announced appear to be a
repackaging
of previous announcements so i can see
the prime minister shaking his head so
can i ask him
to confirm prime minister the exact
figure the uk will contribute to this
marshall plan
for climate action on covent recovery
president biden openly encouraged other
leaders to embrace
the economic logic of an investment-led
recovery
instead of returning to the failed
policy of austerity cuts
does the prime minister agree with that
economic logic and can he therefore
explain why the uk has the smallest
covered stimulus package
of any g7 country and finally in terms
of the
nato summit can the prime minister
detail what
concrete proposals were agreed to apply
appropriate pressure
to protect the human rights of the
persecuted
yogurt muslim minority in china prime
minister
um mr speaker uh on the on the
on the on the uyghurs in in china there
were no concrete measures were discussed
at uh at nato but i've
as i've said in my answer to my uh my
right or honorable friend
uh we remain uh in this country uh
implacably committed to opposing the uh
forced
labor there and to sanctioning uh those
who who profit from
uh from the force forced labour in in
xinjiang
i think his characterization of the
summit is is as as
erroneous as that of the right
honourable gentleman uh we it was a
fantastically successful summit in
bringing the world
together on uh on vaccination
uh on an untackling uh climate change
and as for the the uk's own contribution
uh which he deprecates it's massive and
i think the people of this country will
think it
astonishing at a time at a time when
we've been through
a pandemic and we've spent
407 billion pounds uh looking after jobs
and livelihoods
in this countryhood in this country that
we're still able
uh we're still able and i'll give him
the figure uh we're still able to supply
11.6 billion pounds
11.6 billion pounds uh to help divert
the developing world
uh tackle the consequences of climate
change and he should be proud of that
and not run his country down drew
mitchell
thank you uh mr speaker my right
honourable friend's
significant significant success at the
g7
last weekend has sadly been dented
by the fact that britain is the only g7
country cutting vital aid
and doing so in the middle of a global
pandemic
that decision is not only doing grave
damage
to the reputation of global britain it
will also
lead to more than a hundred thousand
avoidable deaths
principally amongst women and children
will my right honourable friend reflect
on the fact that many of us
in all parts of the parliamentary party
are urging him
to restore these terrible humanitarian
cuts
and that we are not as he suggested in
prime minister's questions last week
lefty propagandists but his political
friends allies and supporters who want
him to think again
prime minister well mrs big i have the
utmost respect for my
my normal friend's record in in overseas
but i have to say that
uh the changes that we've made to oda
weren't have not been raised with me by
anybody at the g7 and not normally
speaking by any
recipient uh country and that is because
and i've talked to many of them i've
talked to many of them and that is
because they know
they know mr speaker that the united
kingdom remains one of the biggest
donors in the world
second in the g7 and in spite of all the
difficulties we've been going through
is contributing 10 billion pounds mr
speaker
to supporting countries this year mr
speaker to supporting countries around
the world and we've just
increased mr speaker our spending on
female education
that was one thing people did raise with
me and they and they and they raised it
with me to congratulate
the uk government on what we were doing
i think people in this country should be
very proud
of the contributions that they're making
let's go to ed derby
ed
the prime minister what's lyrical about
the fight against climate change
but only after stepping off his private
jet
he made the case for investing in girls
education around the world
yet he's cutting the amount we spend on
it by
40 this year he talked up the importance
of
international agreements while reneging
on the one
he signed and he advocated the
importance of democracy
while introducing plans to make it
harder for people to vote in this
country
mr speaker when will the prime minister
realize that his approach of
do as i say not as i do
is ruin us to britain's reputation on
the world stage
well mr speaker i think the liberal
democrats should get their
their facts right we're not cutting uh
spending on
on on girls education uh to pick
one uh the points he made we are
actually increasing it by
at least 15 percent uh 432 million
pounds worth spending on the global
partnership
uh for education mr speaker and i and
when you look at what this country is
doing
on uh on on tackling climate change the
commitment
uh to to net zero uh that was actually
made after
uh we were in coalition with the right
honourable gentleman freed from the
shackles
of lib dem hypocrisy uh mr speaker we
were able to
we were able to get on uh with some
serious work and commit
under my premiership mr speaker freed
from the uselessness of the lib dems to
an 11.6 billion commitment
to helping the people of the world to
tackle climate change mr speaker people
who
he should realize that for for people
who really care
about tackling climate change allowing
the world to build back cleaner
and greener and better listening to him
frankly he's making it harder not just
making it harder to devote lib dem
anyway
thank you mr speaker does my right
honourable friend recall
president macron insisting that nothing
in the northern ireland protocol is
negotiable
even though he admits it contains what
he calls
inconsistencies but if the peace and
stability of northern ireland is being
undermined
by the application of the protocol then
it is obvious
that the protocol itself must be
renegotiated how could
anyone seriously consider otherwise
so will he urge the eu not to give
precedence to the protocol
over the priest process and the good
friday agreement and when you remind
them of the
2017 joint report which included the
aspiration that the then backstop would
be removed
via negotiations and what they called
specific solutions can you pursue that
policy
prime minister mr speaker the problem at
the moment is the application of the
protocol because
the protocol makes it very clear that
there should be no distortions of
of trade and the good friday peace
process above all must be
uh must be upheld but it is being
applied
in a uh in such a way as to destabilize
that
uh peace process and it's being applied
i think in a
in a highly asymmetrical way and all
we're asking
for is some a pragmatic approach and i'm
sure that
uh i hope very much that we'll get that
but if we can't get that then i will
certainly take
the steps that he describes
monday's australian trade deal
announcement revealed the prime
minister's
fear of democratic accountability he's
withheld details of the agreement
and prevented parliament from doing our
proper job of scrutiny
at the proper time yet from day one
australian farmers will be able to
export over
60 times more beef before uk tariffs
kick in
that's no tariff whatsoever on up to 35
000 tons of potentially
low welfare beef so
from day one will he at least commit
to an annual assessment of the economic
impact of his deal
on welsh beef and lamb farmers prime
minister
mr speaker i repeat the points i made to
many members opposite
this is an opportunity for uk farming
and for and indeed for for welsh farmers
and
uh she she speaks with apprehension
about uh
35 000 tons of of australian beef we
already import about 300 000 tons
of eu beef uh mr speaker
uh about 300 000 tons of eu beef
australian farmers observe a very very
high animal welfare
standards and they will only get a
complete free tariff tariff free access
uh after 15 years mr speaker after 15
years
we're going to give people in australia
uh the same rights of access
as we give 27 other eu countries greg
smith
thank you uh mr speaker the recent
agreements on cyber defence policy and
technological
cooperation announced at the nato summit
in brussels will
mean that the alliance remains as strong
as ever
when faced with new threats so will my
rightful friend the prime minister
confirm that he remains utterly
committed
to nato as the foundation of our
collective security
prime minister yes mr speaker nato has
protected
the world and uh and particularly the
european continent for 72
years and it was clear from the
conversation around the table
uh that it will continue to do so for
decades to come let's go to gregory
campbell
gregory thank you mr speaker the
reports are emanating from the summit
that mr micron
doesn't seem to understand the
constitutional parameters of the united
kingdom
given he thought we were part of a
different country will he take steps to
ensure that all our partners know what
those parameters are
and will also take great care in the
next few days
and weeks not to even further jeopardize
devolution in northern ireland
that has been put in jeopardy in the
past few days as a result of sinn fein's
actions
prime minister thank you mr speaker i
thank the owner
what we want to do is to uh strengthen
northern ireland and strengthen northern
ireland's place within the united
kingdom and that's what we're going to
be doing
folks thank you mr speaker can i
congratulate my right-hand friend for
the
success of the g7 which i think did
britain proud
but can i ask him about the nato summit
and in particular whether there were any
discussions about the role for the
alliance in the maintenance and
protection
of energy security in particular the
need to reduce dependence on russia
and can i ask him specifically if there
were any discussions about the strategic
vulnerability
being introduced to europe by the german
selfish obsession
uh for the nordstream 2 project and if
such a discussion did not occur
can you please ensure that it does prime
minister
i i don't think i'm giving anything away
mr speaker
my right honourable friend uh that uh
there were certainly discussions about
the vital importance of
uh all of us getting to net zero and
avoiding
uh a dependence on hydrocarbons uh
whether they're strategically
unwise or not let's go to
caroline lucas caroline lucas
thank you mr speaker the failure of the
g7 to reach an agreement on
ending investment in all fossil fuels
speaks volumes about the prime
minister's true
climate leadership today he mentions
coal but again ignores
oil and gas that's not a green
industrial revolution that is business
as usual
now the international energy agency said
last month that there must be
no new oil gas or coal development if
the world is to reach net zero
so with the success of cop26 now hanging
in the balance
will he heed the call from 101 101
nobel laureates for a global fossil fuel
non-proliferation treaty
and would he pursue that with g7 leaders
and others before the climate summit
or is he happy for that to be judged a
colossal failure of his leadership too
prime minister mr speaker
the summit agreed uh which i thought was
ground but when you consider how much
uh some of these countries are dependent
on coal
i think it was groundbreaking to agree
uh
not to support any more overseas coal
and
the commitments on net zero and on
making progress by 2030
are outstanding and it can be done
her mood of gloom and pessimism is not
shared
by the people of this country we know uh
that
in 2012 40 of our power came
from coal it's now thanks to this
conservative government the actions
we've taken
uh to reduce dependence on coal it's now
down to less than
less than two percent uh and falling the
whole time the whole world knows that
and they're following
the uk's example let's go to derek
thomas
derek thank you mr speaker it's
absolutely right that i congratulate the
prime minister
and all those involved in hosting the g7
summit in my constituency over the
weekend
uh absolutely fantastic event and we've
in common feel very proud that we
of the part we played also to thank the
police who were quite incredible and
traveled from all over the country to
help out
but also an apology for the prime
minister because the truth is that we
are very proud
of the carvers bay declaration and i may
well
mention it once or twice in the years to
come we're proud of the carlos bay
declaration because of the commitments
to covered vaccines we've heard the
education of 40 million
extra girls global climate change
response and also a fairer economic
recovery and job creation
will my friend the prime minister commit
to further opportunities for parliament
to understand the details
of the carbon declaration as they become
available
prime minister yes mr speaker the cab is
based on i thank my own reference the
carbos bay declaration is the foundation
of the uh treaty that this country has
been helping to
prepare and which we've been pioneering
uh for
against any future pandemic and uh the
the crucial elements uh are the zoonotic
uh research hubs the the the pathogen
surveillance network uh the undertakings
to uh
share data to prevent uh barriers
between our countries in
uh the export of uh of ppe medicines
uh vaccines uh and other things it is
the foundation
uh ensuring that a uh the the
time between a new variant arriving at a
new vaccine
should be kept down to 100 days making
sure that we
we spread uh know how and manufacturing
capacity
around the world this is the foundation
of a new global approach
to tackling pandemics the uk has been
absolutely instrumental
in setting uh this up to say nothing of
the funding
that we have put in and i believe that
uh the carbus bay
declaration will be seen as a very very
important step
towards the treaty later this year let's
go to neil hamby
neil thank you thank you mr speaker
and i thank the prime minister for his
update on the g7 summit
however i find myself in the absolutely
curious position of agreeing with one of
my concordian cowboys
predecessors who commented uh on the
commitment secured with the prime
minister in the chair
as an unforgivable moral failure the
agreement is simply not good enough
11 billion vaccines are needed and 1
billion have been promised
50 billion dollars of funding is needed
but only five billion has been promised
the world health organization have said
that covert 19 is moving faster than the
vaccines
and the g7 commitment is simply not
enough
for the aspiration of global britain is
fast becoming a global embarrassment
and more indicative of a dell boy
britain will the prime minister now show
real leadership
and redouble such efforts to secure the
suspension of intellectual property
protections
secure further international efforts to
prevent new variants developing
and i would appeal to his self-interest
that none of us are safe
until everyone is safe prime minister
mr speaker he i'm afraid he's he's is
running down
uh the uk's efforts he's also running
down what the summit achieved
uh a billion more vaccines on top of the
uh the billion that the the g7 countries
have already committed to distributing
around the world at a time where it's
only six months after these vaccines
were invented
uh mr speaker uh it is a quite
astonishing
thing and he attacks uh the performance
of of britain
and the uk uh and the uk and the people
of the he's
uh let me let me just remind him that we
in this country
are responsible for one-third of the 1.5
billion
vaccines that are being distributed
around the world
when he is he going to get that into his
head it is a fantastic record
on top of the 1.6 billion that we've
been contributing
uh to that kovacs uh that kovacs rollout
uh mr speaker i think the people of this
country should be immensely proud
of the the carbus bay declaration of the
vaccines contribution
that we're making uh we are working as
fast and as hard as we can
while we are still getting vaccines into
the arms of our own people
in this country and that is absolutely
right
thank you mr speaker the communiques
from both the g7 and nato summit speak
of the increasing challenges
and threats from china be they military
build up or cyber attacks
human rights abuses or the belt and road
initiative
so can i write honourable friend
reassure the house that the common
values and commitment that we and our
partners have
to democracy and the rules-based
international order
will result in both the g7 and nato
tackling the malign actions of the
chinese communist party
whatever form they take prime minister
yes mr speaker i think nobody at either
the g7 or
at nato uh wants to get into a new cold
war
with china but on the other hand they
see
that the opportunities that we have to
trade more with china to engage
with china must be matched with firmness
in our collective dealings with china
particularly when it comes to the
uyghurs of
as colleagues have mentioned several
times when it comes to
navigation in the south china sea and to
the freedoms and rights of the people of
hong kong
let's go to stephen ferry steven
uh thank you mr speaker the northern
protocol was a key theme on the margins
of the g7 summit
the biden administration has made clear
that they want to see the good friday
agreement upheld
and made the point that while there is
no immediate prospect of the u.s free
trade agreements
a uk eu veterinary agreement would not
compromise that trade deal in any event
the prime minister has already said that
he wants to get rid of the checks across
the irc
so why is he so stubbornly resisting
that ready-made solution
even on a temporary basis to reduce
those checks across the areas sea
and to ease tensions in the north
islands and indeed to help all uk
food exporters prime minister well i i
hope it won't have escaped the
honourable gentleman's attention that
we've just signed a free trade agreement
with australia
uh mr speaker we intend to do many more
let's go to
tom tugan tom thank you
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
knows that uh treaties can occasionally
be negotiated not quite make it
through the house of commons in the
interests of making sure we deliver
what we need to in cop26 building on the
impressive work of not just the g7 and
nato statements but also trade deals
like that
with australia will he commit to making
sure that this house
is informed well in advance of cop
agreements so that we can assist advise
and perhaps even
make sure that those agreements pass
easily and smoothly to this house
and encourage others to do the same
prime minister
i will do my best to oblige uh the
honourable gentleman though
uh my experience of this matter over the
last few years is
this house uh is a great legislator but
not
an ideal negotiator let's go to hillary
ben
hillary thank you very much
mr speaker the g7 announcement of a
billion additional vaccine doses for
developing
countries was of course welcome but the
prime minister knows that the head of
the world
health organization says that we need 11
billion doses in total if we're going to
vaccinate 70
of the world's population where does the
right honourable gentleman think the
rest of these doses
are going to come from so that everyone
can be safe
because everyone is vaccinated
mr speaker one of the most important
things that we agreed at the g7 was not
just
uh the the kabus bay principles that
i've i've outlined
uh that will form part of the the health
treaty
but also that we should work together to
increase uh vaccine manufacturing
capacity
fill and finish facilities around the
world particularly
in in sub-saharan africa i i have to
tell him uh
that you know it it is only a few months
since these vaccines
were invented uh we're going as fast as
we can
but our ambition is to vaccinate the
world by the end of next year
debbie thank you mr speaker the g7
meeting was
exactly the face modern britain should
present to the world competent and
confident
in terms of the substance the uk
commitment to share
100 million vaccines with less developed
countries
is of course an extremely welcome first
step can my writing will friend
guarantee that the 70 million doses that
will be delivered
through 2022 will be in addition to our
existing aid budget yes
yes i can mr speaker chris brown i kept
on thinking all weekend
thank god biden beat trump yes
certainly mate i think the prime
minister's nodding um
can i just ask following the carbus bay
declaration can i urge the prime
minister to come to wales to sign a
cardiff bay
declaration this would include
radical extra investment in wales to do
the leveling up that the prime minister
i think intends
so that every person whether they live
in the valleys of south wales or they
live
in um the posture parts of cardiff or
swansea or wherever has an
equal chance of getting to work an equal
chance of
putting food on the table for their kids
an equal chance of getting on in life
and frankly an equal chance of having an
nhs which is really able to protect them
because the
problems that we have in wales are
exactly the same as in england we need
significant extra investment and the
only way we can achieve that
is by real hard cooperation between the
government in westminster
and the government in wales
yes of course mr speaker we've massively
increased support for the
uh for the nhs for instance for uh all
of which is
is passported through to uh to wales
uh funding has massively increased i
think it will be uh
and of course we work very closely with
the government in in cardiff the
administration
in cardiff i think it would be helpful
in delivering great infrastructure
uh for wells whether uh improving the
a55 or
uh or the m4 uh if uh there was some
consistency
of approach and uh the m4 bypass for
instance
uh the bring glass tunnels i think it
was crazy to spend 144 million pounds
of taxpayers money 144 million on a
study
without actually doing the bypass itself
very happy to work with the welsh labour
government they get their act together
let's go to john redwood sir john
uh no less than five representatives of
the european union at the g7
tried to hijack the agenda to undermine
the people of northern ireland with
their one-sided and unfair view of the
protocol
will the prime minister who chaired it
well makes sure goods can flow freely in
the uk internal market
given there are legal ways of doing this
unilaterally
doesn't the good friday agreement
require the eu
and the uk to respect the needs and
wishes of both
communities mr yes mr speaker of course
i thank my right honourable friend he's
completely right and it was the
the uk who really shocked people in uh
it was the eu i should say who shocked
people in uh in northern ireland by
invoking article 16 of the protocol in
in january and uh trying to put a a
barrier
for the movement of vaccines between the
eu and
and the uk uh we never would have
dreamed of doing
uh something like that but that it was
it was that action that undermined
uh people's faith in the protocol let's
go to joanna chara
joanna mr speaker
the recent violence and the loss of
innocent life in gaza and israel
underlines the importance of restarting
the middle east peace process
britain has historic and continuing
responsibilities in this region
so can the prime minister tell us what
steps he took at the weekend to
raise and progress the restarting
of this important peace process in the
middle east
prime minister uh mr speaker we remain
committed and i've as i i raise
continuously
uh with uh friends and partners around
the world
uh we remain committed as to our friends
in the
in the eu and in washington uh to a
two-state solution
for the middle east let's go to alex
shelbrook alex
thank you mr speaker can i first of all
congratulate my right honourable friend
on the successful hosting of the g7
after the trauma the world has just been
through and at the nato summit the
discussion of nato 2030 he will
recognize is one of the most important
assessments
and forward thinking that nato has
undertaken in many a decade reinforced
unity
a broader approach to security
safeguarding the laws based
international order
does my rightful friend agree with me
that our position
in cyber and space defense not only
makes us still one of the biggest
contributors to nato but also makes us
one of the integral partners of the
alliance
minister yes and i thank my honor
because
the uh the nato's project 2030
that dien stoltenberg set out at the
summit
is actually completely uh in accordance
and
almost an echo of the integrated review
uh that the government set out
with its emphasis on cyber and on
on space defenses thank you mr speaker
i've sat listening to the writingable
and gentleman's statement this afternoon
and one of the things i'm proud of is
visiting our schools
at my school's in vauxhall and speaking
to young people and writing world
friends said yesterday
last week girls education is the best
way we can lift countries out of poverty
and lead the global recovery
i heard the writing war members response
to the member for saturn coalfield
around the fact that the g7 leaders did
not mention the global aid cut
if that's the case does my right and
will friend agree that his actions
shows a gaping hole between his words
and actions and will he respect this
house
by bringing that vote to parliament and
bring that decision here
prime minister actually again again
what i did hear from the leaders around
the world
was massive overwhelming support for the
objective that she supports